a new report just issued by NOAA says
September's Arctic sea ice coverage was
about 25% less than it was between 1981
and 2010 as America's only Arctic state
Alaska today faces unique challenges one
of those is the loss of permafrost
frozen earth that serves as a foundation
for huge portions of the state
as we discovered on a recent trip to
Alaska the permafrost is thawing
presenting multiple threats soon a tally
of the Woods Hole Research Center has
been taking trips like this deep into
the remote corners of Alaska's
wilderness permission monitor how
warming air temperatures are impacting
the frozen earth underground permafrost
is frozen ground it's ground that
remains below 0 degrees Celsius for two
or more consecutive years water rocks so
everything everything in that ground
that's frozen is permafrost but that
term is actually misleading because as
an Italian other field scientists are
learning find a nice flat spot the icy
soil buried under this spongy moss is
anything but permanent I'm gonna dig a
hole recent studies show Arctic
permafrost has warmed by up to two
degrees Celsius in the past three
decades and predict that 20% of it may
thaw by 2040
natella uses this drill to extract
permafrost which starts a few feet under
the surface and can extend hundreds of
feet down it contains organic material
from dead and partially decayed plants
and animals this is a permafrost core
yeah this is how we sample permafrost
some of its been frozen for thousands of
years but as it thaws that organic
material releases gases like methane and
carbon dioxide the so called greenhouse
gases that warm the atmosphere our
projections say for the larger
permafrost region is we can expect 150
billion tons of carbon to really be
released by 2100 based on current
emissions the u.s. is already expected
to release that much carbon over the
same time period just by burning fossil
fuels this thawing permafrost would
effectively double that figure we're
inside the permafrost tunnel so we're
walking inside of permafrost the best
view of permafrost does come from
underground in this 50 year old tunnel
built and maintained by the US Army
Corps of Engineers just outside
Fairbanks you can see there these
massive frozen structures that have
formed over tens of thousands of years
down here it's easy to visualize another
danger posed by thawing ground and you
can imagine if this the permafrost thaws
in this really large ice wedge here
melts out that you're gonna have some
pretty substantial ground collapse it's
already happening in Alaska forests of
trees bent or toppled over roads like
roller coaster tracks even neighborhoods
of homes buckling into uneven ground so
at each end the live as a surface was
flat University of Alaska researcher
Alexander Kola daf studies permafrost
loss using hundreds of sensors around
the northern hemisphere
he says the data from almost all those
stations points to the same trend
it isn't really warm so that's really
close to freezing point so it's actually
very very vulnerable now you're right
you're right on the line there yes we
are right on a line now on a border line
another possible side effect of
permafrost loss thawing remains of long
dead animals could release dormant
diseases last summer the first fatal
Russian outbreak of anthrax in 75 years
killed a child in sick in 20 but the
more immediate impacts remain the rapid
release of methane and carbon dioxide
and of course if your house or your
business is built on permafrost
fascinating it is fascinating because
I'm thinking we're just walking around
living our lives I've never heard the
word firm for us really until today and
it's nice to know that there's people
out there bringing it to our attention
like yourself and those researchers to
say people we need to do something about
this every day one of the most amazing
states in the world Alaska it's
beautiful such a beautiful place